- [Voiceover] If and
initial investment, P,
bears an inter, bears interest a rate, r.
So this is initial investment
P, bears interest at a rate r.
And is compounded annually,
it's future value, A, after t years
can be determined with the equation above.
Which of the following equations
shows the interest rate
in terms of the future
value, initial investment,
and number of years invested?
So they really just
want us to solve for r.
So let's see if we can do that.
So we have the future value.
Let me give myself some space.
Future value is equal,
I'm just rewriting it,
is equal to the initial investment
times one plus r, interest rate.
And then that quantity to the the t power.
So let's see what we can do.
So the first thing I can
do is I can get the P
onto the left hand side
by dividing both sides
of this equation by
our initial investment.
So if I do that, I get,
and actually let me,
let me swap the sides, too.
Then I get one plus r to the t power
is equal to our future value,
divided by our initial investment.
Now how do I get rid of
this to the t power here?
Well I could raise both sides
to the one over t power.
So I could raise that to the
one over t power, one over t.
If I do it on the left side, I have to
do it to the right side as well.
So, on the left-hand side, if
I raise something to the t,
and then I raise it to the one over t.
Remember if you raise
something to an exponent
and then raise it to another exponent,
you're raising it to the
product of these two exponents.
So this is equivalent to raising one.
This is equivalent to
just raising one plus r
to the first power, or this
is just going to simplify
to one plus r on the left hand side.
And on the right hand
side, we're gonna have our
future value divided by
our initial investment
to the one over t power.
And now pretty straight forward.
You wanna solve for r,
subtract one from both sides,
we get r is equal to our future value
divided by our initial investment
to the one over t power minus one.
And that is this choice right over there.